- What's up guys, it's Evan
coming to you from London.
We are at Tower Bridge.
I wanted to talk to you guys about my book
and I want some feedback.
So I'm launching a new book,
it's going to be The
Top 10 Rules of Success.
I'm taking the 50 most popular profiles
that we've ever done on the channel,
the one's that have had the most views,
and I condense them down.
So it's going to be a book
that has two rules per page.
So if we're looking at
Richard Branson or Mark Cuban
or Oprah Winfrey or any
of the big entrepreneurs
and celebrities and people
that we've profiled.
Some of those videos can be long.
Some of those videos can
be 20, 30, 40 minutes
and so what I'm doing is
taking it to two rules per page
so you can get through
everything super quickly.
The ideas, I wanted to be
something that you look at every morning
but not something that you
read all the way through.
Read one page.
This is my thought.
I want you to read one page per day.
It's super easy to read one page per day.
And then think about it.
Think about the lesson
that you just learned
and then try to find some way to apply it
to your life or to your business.
The idea is if you read a page a day
and thought about these great things
that people are teaching you,
it changes your environment.
It changes, hopefully,
your morning routine,
your structure, what you think about.
And what you surround
yourself with matters.
If you are on a daily
basis feeding yourself
with ideas from people
who have accomplished
some of the greatest things in the world,
you can't help but get greater yourself.
If you are surrounded by people that have
big, bold, passionate ideas
that they're off making a
huge change in the world,
you can't help but be
a little bit more bold,
little bit more courageous yourself.
That was the idea behind making this book,
behind the structure of
reading one page per day.
I want your feedback.
What do you think about the idea?
Any thoughts, suggestions that you have
to make it better.
The book is supposed
to come out December 6.
That's at least my goal.
It was December 6 that
I launched my last book
and so
I thought on the anniversary
of that thing coming out,
Your One Word that I do the second book.
So I'd love to get your support on that.
One other thing that's in the book as well
is I took the 10 most common
lessons that are in the book.
So I basically, we have 50
entrepreneurs, 10 rules each.
That's 500 different rules
and took the most popular 10 that came up
over and over and over
and over and over again.
And that's something that you
guys have asked for a lot.
What are the most common rules?
What are the ones that keep coming up?
And so the book will actually lead
with those 10 most common rules
and then get into entrepreneur at a time,
one entrepreneur at a time
with their top 10 rules.
And so I want your feedback.
What do you think of the idea?
I want your suggestions.
How can I make the book even
more awesome than it is?
I'm going to be,
hopefully soon, getting my
test audience of 30 people in Toronto
to read through the actual
book and give me feedback.
This one is actually
going to be self-published
as opposed to Your One Word
that I went with a major publisher
so if you want to get
any answers to questions
on the self-publishing
process, let me know.
Just looking forward to your thoughts,
suggestions, feedback, and support.
I really appreciate it.
It's been on my mind as I
walk through London today.
So looking forward to
hear what you have to say.
Leave it down in the comments below.
So thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you.
Hope we continue to believe in yourself
and whatever Your One Word is, much love.
See you soon.